[Music]
missouri now you come back saying you
know a little bit about every little
thing they ever hoped you'd never figure
out the reds see the dead sea the summon
on the mail you want to see a miracle
oh yeah josh redder has been called one
of our greatest living songwriters he's
been on this show multiple times
including this performance from 2016
recorded live at san francisco's the
fillmore but today we're focusing on
another one of his endeavors his second
novel the great glorious god damn of it
all is set to be released on tuesday
it's set in idaho in the early 1900s
during the last days of the lumberjacks
before modern machines changed the
business forever it's where ritter now
based in new york city was raised and
recently we joined him
for a trip back
[Music]
there's so many places now it feels like
it's so easy to fly over and coming down
here where the trees you walk off at the
edge of town and the trees just swallow
you up it's so exciting
[Music]
josh ritter grew up in a valley
surrounded by striking mountains and
towering conifers
western idaho has always been essential
to him you miss this place yeah i really
do i think about it a lot i think that
the the most powerful moment sometimes
that i that i have in my year is when i
come back to idaho and i smell the the
pine trees and the uh for the first time
again ritter's new book the great
glorious goddamn of it all is a love
letter to both his childhood home
and a long gone way of life it tells the
story of a young boy the son of a timber
man as he comes of age during the last
days of the lumberjacks at the beginning
of the 20th century he's shaped by not
only the landscape and the the mountains
and the trees around him but he's shaped
by these mortal enemies that he has that
that he believes keeps him alive and uh
in that kind of orness and that that
willingness to take on all comers is
something that i was really i thought
was fascinating and so fun
the journey of ritter's protagonist
weldon applegate can be as enjoyable to
read as ritter's career has been to
watch sunday night at suppertime the
hotel's full and all is fine he started
with songs strumming onto the scene as a
teenager in the 1990s he's since
released 10 albums featuring his
unmistakable version of americana
[Music]
a decade ago ritter released his first
book the critically acclaimed brights
passage when i first started writing i
thought this is going to be great i
don't have to rhyme i don't have to like
i don't have to drag my gear with me
everywhere i go you know and then i
found out that i was
it was still like it all came down to
putting the perfect word after the
perfect word you realize it's still
writing and it's still hard it's still
hard yeah yeah it's hard it's really
hard and i've never been more
embarrassed in my life than sitting
alone in my room at the end of the day a
readings back something that i wrote
that is that is no good you know
it's a log drive in idaho the great
glorious god damn of it all takes
readers back in time to a dangerous and
demanding world when lumberjacks had to
fell trees with arms and axes then
transport them by ox so they could be
floated down rivers in the days prior to
heavy machinery
the monarchs of the forest have been
humble to satisfy the needs of men
yeah they didn't have these 150 years
ago no
when combustion engines came around
people must have been so excited
in the book ritter highlights a
mysterious place called the last lot a
remote timber spot full of majestic furs
and pines that is thought to be
impossible to harvest it was fun to read
about the real job and then to blow it
up into myth make it bigger than it
possibly could have been i think there's
sometimes you go outside and you don't
you walk by trees but you don't really
look at them yeah i think this this book
makes you look at them thank you yeah
thank you i think that there's like
there's something just
tremendous and and magical about walking
underneath the bows of some of those big
trees you know sometimes walking
underneath those trees like you're in a
cathedral like that's the cathedral is
is really is trying to be what what a
tree is like they're older than us
they're bigger than us yeah they've seen
more than us yeah i had a dream last
night
rusting far below me battered holes and
broken hardships leviathan and lonely is
the satisfaction that you get from
writing a novel
different than writing a song
i think of both as as
whether it's a song or a novel it's a
dispatch back from a far away place
[Music]
a song maybe like a postcard and you
imagine everything around it but a book
is like a full travelogue
today ritter is already hard at work on
his next novel and is also about to get
back to something else you're about to
start shows again yeah yeah yeah the
first time since
for the beginning of last year yeah yeah
in the year and a half
performing is so necessary for me for my
creative life it pours all the energy
into my fuel tanks peter killed the
dragon and he did it with his bare hands
my wife haley says that the roots of
every religion are people in a room
making music and i think that that's
like something i've always believed he's
starting with smaller more intimate
shows a way for people to ease back into
live music
but because so many of us are still
spending so much time at home and not in
crowds ritter's fans now have a new
outlet
for his prolific storytelling with books
you're getting a chance to go through
the door of your imagination into a
whole new world and
that's just
kind of irresistible to me
i love when he talks about the smell of
the pines
every year when he goes back it's just
there's something about the smell and
the scenery in this section of the
country that you don't get anywhere else
not just in this country but around the
world i loved when he said a song as a
postcard but a book is like a travel oh
yeah yeah wow